for today's classic interview the last
classic interview of 2016 next week
we'll be running a countdown of our top
shows on Fridays it is the official last
show of the year but this week is sort
of our last new 2016 show of the year
we're going back to just a good old
fashioned conspiracy theory interview I
love a good conspiracy theory and that's
exactly what James Herson brought us
back in May of 2014 I won't take too
much time introducing it because he
explains it so much more eloquently than
I ever could it relates to mandatory
microchipping and tracking the RFID of
Americans with no further delay let's
get to my interview with James Herson a
true classic I'm joined today by James
Herson he's in New York Times
bestselling author commentator media
analyst and law professor James is also
the co-founder and chief legal counsel
for international es q dot com which is
a legal think tank and educational
institute for the study of law in the
media James great to have you on we
haven't interviewed you before you've
done investigative stories on a number
of different topics and one is on
microchipping and what you consider to
be the possibility of mandatory
microchipping in the future so let's
start at the very top when you talk
about microchipping broadly what are we
talking about well we're talking about a
small computer chip getting smaller and
smaller known as a radio frequency
identification chip these chips send out
signals that can be used to identify
their in the form of either numbers or
alphanumeric code or computer code they
also can be tied to databases and
they're small enough to be injected with
a hypodermic needle and they are placed
routinely today across the world in
animals for identification of animals
the thing has happened you mentioned
that about this view of mandatory
microchipping being my opinion it's
actually the opinion of many respected
academics who are now um sort of joining
the mainstream they call themselves
transhumanists
these are people who believe that the
future of mankind or the next step for
human beings is to become one with
technology kind of a cyborg as a matter
of fact one of them dr. kevin warwick
his nickname is Captain cyborg and these
folks and their followers including many
young people who call themselves
biohackers have injected themselves with
these chips many times using the chip
kits that are sold for animals and done
various things with them right now what
most of them are doing is opening doors
starting cars interfacing with
technology with their smart phones or
computers and things like that although
dr. warg did an experiment where he was
able to move a robot arm thousands of
miles away by placing his chip into the
internet much like a sort of uh preview
of Johnny Depp's film transcendence
which viewed the future of somebody
uploading their personality into a
quantum computer and ultimately into the
internet right yes my concern is and I'm
very interested in this because we've
interviewed transhumanists we have
scientists on the program all the time
we try to stay on top of new
technologies technologies but the
problem is we have a serious level of
threat inflation in this country around
so many things and the RFID mandatory
microchipping ideas while you're right
that there are some so-called
transhumanist scientists who think at
some point there might be mandatory
microchipping this idea about humans
combining with technology is not really
a new idea right or combining with
machines pacemakers contact lenses
prosthetic limbs the idea that the RFID
chip is a drastically different
combination of humans and machines at
than all of the others seems to be at
its face just incorrect and it's the
basis as you said for so many of these
theories well I think it is different it
here's why yeah now we have a two trend
lines that are very disturbing you know
one of them on its own
would not be moore's law says that
technology increases geometrically every
18 months and we've seen that we now
carry around a smartphone that has the
computer power of a computer 30 years
ago that would be on entire floor of a
college campus so we see the technology
increasing but let's do we have to stop
there though James that's not even
Moore's law right you're misstating
Moore's law uiii assume you know that
that's not what it is or maybe you don't
Moore's Law is just that in the history
of computing hardware the number of
transistors on integrated circuits
doubles approximately every two years
what you're saying is not completely
unrelated but that wasn't Moore's law
okay well thank you for that correction
but the fact is the technology is
increasing at a extremely rapid pace no
question about it if we look at the
history of humans if you look at the
last hundred years right I mean we've
seen exponential technological growth no
question about it and we now have also
an increase in the world in for tative
government throughout the world now if
you look at history talked about history
the norm for human beings was not the
freedom that we enjoy in the West it the
norm was people living under tyranny and
when you have an increase in tyranny and
an increase in technology there is cause
for concern we had Edward Snowden's
revelations we have had a mandate past
and blessed by the united states supreme
court that says that the law requires
every citizen of the united states to
make a purchase that same precedent can
easily be applied to what both political
parties are pushing for a national ID
card and we've all seen this sort of
evolution from ID cards to rfid
technology already in my home state of
Illinois where I'm originally from two
big retail chains no longer use credit
cards they use the swype fingerprints
and I can see it easy
Lee a time where a mandatory microchip
would be required let me give you one
example the NBC news recently had a
story and they were extolling the
positives of a microchip and the way
they did it of course is with a victim
and that was an individual who was taken
to the emergency room and who died
because they couldn't get access to the
individuals medical records and G if
they only would have had a little
implanted chip like their pet does that
could have had access to a database that
would have in fact supply the medical
information sure but at the same time
there would be many other methods also
right i mean if we had a better system
of of nationalized electronic medical
records there are countless ways in
which that particular situation could
have been avoided well but not for
example if you have an elderly patient
who doesn't have ID and doesn't have a
something that we tie into their medical
records they were brought to the
hospital unconscious there's a whole
bunch of reasons and ways that this is
now slowly being sold right and I think
that's one of them and the fact is the
RFID technology as we talked about is
getting smaller and increasing and it's
something that for you know when we look
at the health care law easily right now
based on the 2,700 pages and the huge
delegation that from Congress gave to
the executive branch the successor to
Kathleen Sebelius could implement a
mandatory chip as a prerequisite for
this for the Affordable Care a but see
here James here now you're really
serving up the meat of this to me on an
honest on a tea because this is exactly
where I think we're crossing over into
into the into the weeds which is that
the hypothetical you're suggesting there
were countless articles saying that
there was mandatory microchipping
provider that there were such provisions
in the Affordable Care Act there were
connections with the religious right
claiming that rfid chips are the quote
mark of the beast and you're literally
hold on now you're literally crossing
over now into the extremist territory
and my view my view here okay no I
understand you didn't say that yeah go
ahead wait wait wait wait yeah don't put
words in my mouth I wasn't did not say
that it was in the act I didn't accuse
you of saying that though James were
false rice ball correct it is true that
the law is so ambiguous that if the
executive branch through HHS decided
today right require as a condition of
their policies that they're issuing on
the state exchanges that people had were
checked that law that power exists based
on the precedent of the United States
Supreme Court I disagree with you I
completely disagree with you on that but
it would be up to the Supreme Court to
decide you or I are not going to
ultimately decide that no no if the case
says that using the taxing power that it
is now okay to mandate that citizens
purchase something or pay a penalty if
you can mandate that citizens purchase a
service or a product you can also
mandate that they purchase a and RFID
chip I'm sorry that that's what I
happened I'm a lawyer I have appeared in
front of the Supreme Court um that's
what lawyers argue but James James if
we're going to go down that road you
must admit that saying RFID chip is
completely arbitrary in other words
under that logic we could be saying hey
if they wanted to they could mandate
people purchase anything at all and and
then it makes that but then it makes the
conversation about the RFID chip
completely irrelevant now you know the
history for example a verra chip and you
understand that Vera chip got in trouble
with their public relations because they
did in fact implant 200 of these RFID
chips into the elderly that we're in a
nursing home without the proper
of government many of whom could not
consent and now they've changed their
name to positive idea much more sunshiny
name that's fine but James net that's a
private company that's a private company
here's the let me step back for a second
the broad point I want to make and we
are running short on time as fascinating
as i find this is that i don't think the
unlike you that there's anything unique
about rfid technology compared to other
technology in the sense that as for all
of human history every new technology
has been both number one subject to
interference and surveillance and number
two subject to misuse and I don't think
and I've not been convinced that there's
anything different about RFID technology
well there's something very different
RFID technology is so small it goes into
the body and as long as of course the
lifespan of the chip exists it's stuck
in the body and if it's a injected in
the body theoretically and forgive me
you're going to accuse me I'm wearing a
tinfoil hat but it can be injected
without people knowing and we have a
history of governments doing this sort
of thing I mean did we know until Edward
Snowden told us about the surveillance
absolutely anybody who was paying even
the most remote attention after nine
eleven and saw what was passed had was
what as absolutely not even remotely
surprised by the revelations of that
really notice puhlease the Patriot Act
looks is a tiny microcosm compared to
what Snowden revealed then and no one
was surprised then why is Snowden hiding
in Russia I mean the fact is well
because he broke laws and he doesn't
want to get arrested amounts of metadata
the public was totally unaware Greg
Greenwald is being heralded Glenn's
reporting on this has a book out at it
it was a surprise all right there enough
James Hurston this it is a fascinating
discussion New York Times bestselling
author commentator media analyst law
professor we didn't agree but that's ok
very interesting conversation thanks for
being with us ok
for having me